[Música]
no es la primera vez que Jeff Jenny
trigosin amenaza con retirar las fuerzas
pero si es la primera vez que le pone
fecha ha dicho que si no le llega la
munición que lleva pidiendo desde hace
meses y semanas él retirará a sus
hombres el 10 de mayo Un día después de
que en Rusia se celebra ese desfile de
la Victoria en el cual se Recuerda la
victoria de la unión soviética contra la
Alemania nazi que ha tomado un papel aún
más importante desde la invasión a gran
escala ordenada por Vladimir Putin el
año pasado ellos quieren Mostrar la
grandeza de Rusia una grandeza que ha
quedado demostrada que no la tienen
después de esa invasión especialmente
desde campo militar donde se han visto
tantas fallas en su ejército y también
porque se le ha visto delegar muchas de
esas batallas especialmente
en tropas paramilitares como la
depilosina parecía en ese video
mostrando muchos de sus hombres muertos
que habían muerto en los últimos días en
combate Y decía que esto era culpa de
que no le daban esa munición sin embargo
lo que dicen desde Ucrania especialmente
el portavoz de las fuerzas militares del
este del país es que ellos no han visto
escasez de municiones las tropas de
Wagner
en las que llevan en sus rifles ni
tampoco en artillería por el contrario
dicen que siguen luchando con la misma
intensidad lo que sí ha pasado es que
muchos más hombres han muerto en los
últimos días esto no solamente lo
confirma el portavoz del ejército sino
que también nosotros lo hemos oído de
hombres en el terreno nos cuentan en las
cercanías de bakú que muchos hombres
rusos han muerto en los últimos días y
también nos contaban que a pesar de la
intensidad y la dureza de las batallas
los ucranianos han logrado capturar un
par de calles nuevas en los últimos días
se crea Aquí que básicamente esto sigue
siendo o esta amenaza es una pelea
interna dentro de Rusia como se ve esta
semana te digo sin con la cúpula militar
por ganarse los favores y las miradas de
vla